paris juin dernier un français dans les
médias a rendez vous pour une entrevue
avec guy corneau dans son appartement
parisien
une heure pas plus il invite son ami
notre photographe nadine à prendre des
photos puis puis j'étais pas vraiment
prête pour un photoshoot à l'intérieur
pour un portrait elle résiste ne crois
pas avoir le bon équipement et de toute
façon et n'a jamais entendu parler de ce
corps nos le psy ou de la peindre et
soeurs du psychiatre non il y là il a
voulu regarder que je faisais donc là
j'étais déjà flatté qu'il faut
intéresser
il faut absolument rencontre oui je
parle un peu de ce que je fais de mon
exposé puis une vie il faut que tu
rencontres master jai dias et qui c'est
qui va devoir alors il sourit comme cela
il y est encore long j'ai dit car non
quant aux com com du corps non il y eu
copie que ce prix là il a compris que je
n'avais aucune idée de fieffés saveurs
ou même détruits ils étaient entre la
photographe et son sujet s'installe
climat de sympathie de confiance qui
dérape vers la confidence la dig traque
croit en effet depuis longtemps que
l'essentiel se cachent dans les yeux de
ces sujets ce qu'elle voit ce que sa
caméra lui confirme c'est que ce jour-là
l'inconscient du psychanalyste c'est
laisser saisir son sourire
trahi par la tristesse qui hante ses
yeux un slam or qui se fait voir la
sienne ou celle de sa soeur ce qui m'a
frappé le plus il a été clair dans ces
lieux
yahvé allah creusement et revu une joie
de vivre un sens de l'humour mais en
même temps avec une profonde tristesse
quand il a fini l'entrevue et puis
j'avais un peu connu et qui qui comme
non je lui ai demandé de poser pour moi
donc là il souriait avait le sourire à
un peu plus à dison marketing puis j'ai
tellement vu ce regard profond dans ses
vieux que je lui ai demandé d'arrêter
couvrir parce que c'était tellement fort
que ça marchait pas ça fait t'es pas
puis je lui ai dit je pense à quelque
chose pour faire un montage avec notre
photo
j'espère que tu vas pas trouvé ça trop
quétaine de 10 le mur des je t'aime
c'est sur nos matous si vous connaissez
ça c'est écrit je t'aime en 360 l'est
pas alors il sourit à son téléphone puis
il me montre le mur qu'il avait pris il
ya deux jours le mur des je t'aime il
dit li était il ya des jours je dis moi
aussi c'est fou je dis peut-être qu'il
faudrait essayer un montage du riz
pourquoi pas ça la fait sourire
christophe qui n'étaient pas habitués à
des choses artistiques ces photos sont
très très très simple rencontre
d'appartements qui ne devait durer
qu'une heure c'est un sur quatre heures
s'est déplacé dans un restaurant puis
c'est la sainte des adieux
le portrait qui la rente mais qu'elle
n'a pas su photographier elle vient le
grave est par ces mots maintenant dans
notre mémoire collective
c'est la dernière image de monsieur
corps non qui m'a qui me reste est
peut-être dire femme revient à me
revient souvent mais il est parti dans
la direction du café de flore ou des
deux magots ces deux cafés la censure
faverdin des prêts c'était le lieu de
rencontre des grands écrivains les
grands penseurs précisément jean paul
sartre simone de beauvoir
donc il s'est ému devant ce qu'a fait là
et il me disait un dernier au revoir et
corriger et il nous a envoyé un bisou
volant pour remercier du photoshoot puis
du tout avec un grand grand sourire
angélique et les dieux très brillant ça
c'est très petit fille car monsieur
canon et j'ai regardé j'ai dit j'ai dit
c'est surréel cette scène là j'ai
monsieur corps non derrière lui le café
de flore la plaque baida il était sur la
place d'ali baba à lui le café de flore
les deux magots on dirait qu'il
appartient à un autre monde le monde des
grands et je m'étais pas rendu compte
qu'en ce moment là je l'avais laissée
avec les grands et qu'il était allé les
rejoindre
gillet fanti j'ai senti que c'était
surréel comme cadre et je m'étais dit
c'est dommage aurait dû lui prendre une
photo issue en dernier mais je me suis
retourné puis voilà c'était la dernière
image qui qui m'arrive t un reportage de
radio canada international